today we're going to talk about
clustering do you ever find when you're
on YouTube you'll watch a video on
something and then suddenly you're being
recommended a load of other videos that
you hadn't even heard of that are
actually kind of similar this happens to
me I watched some video on some new type
of saw trying to learn it because you
know don't know what I'm doing and
suddenly I'm being recommended videos on
turning verses on wooden lathes and all
kinds of weird stuff and what's
happening is I'm being clustered into
groups of people who are liking those
and watching those kind of videos or
these kind of videos are all being
clustered together as similar right so
clustering is it's one of the sort of
core technologies at the heart of this
kind of stuff in fairness I did end up
watching a bunch of those woodturning
videos we've talked about the different
kinds of datasets you might have right
and until up to now we've been talking
about things like cleaning data
transforming data and reducing data now
what we want to do is start trying to
derive some knowledge now sort of a
typical way to do this would be
something like a classification
algorithm or maybe a regression ad with
them but today we're going to talk about
how do you separate out data and group
data together when we don't have any
labels for that data so this is an
example of unsupervised learning
different types of machine learning that
we can use one is unsupervised this is
where we don't have any labels then we
have supervised learning where we have
labels so for example a supervised
learning task might be one where you
have some labels for you for your
products or your videos and you're
trying to classify them like that so
maybe you're trying to classify videos
into a genre right or unsupervised
learning we don't have any labels maybe
we've just got a load of products and
we're trying to group them into into
similar categories so these are all the
tools and these will be electronic
products and these are all the toys
right and maybe we want to do that
without having to have a person go
through and click on them all so why
wouldn't we just label everything and
then use that to perform nice powerful
machine learning algorithms like
classification well sometimes it's just
too expensive to produce labels if
you're running a music recommendation
system
I like the wonder power Spotify maybe
going through and defining what genre
everything is by hand is going to take
absolutely ages and one waste of time
right way if we can do this
automatically so sometimes you aren't
gonna have labels for data and it's too
expensive to obtain it's too
time-consuming it's too difficult maybe
you don't people disagree over what John
or two pieces of music are so in that
case you are going to have labels and so
clustering is a good option right let's
group things together with things that
are similar in terms of their attributes
without actually knowing what they are
what we're going to try and do then is
take all the attributes and all the
instances objects and use them to group
them into similar objects but the
question is what is similar like well
let's think back to the way that we
structure our data we're going to have
rows as our instances and we're going to
have columns as our attributes and
another way we remember to think about
that is that these actually are data
points in some space where the position
of each point or the position of each
instance depends on the attributes so
for example we could have a three
attribute data set so maybe we have Row
1 2 3 4 and we have attribute a B and C
right so I don't know maybe one has a
value for a in a value for B and a value
for C so this means this is a sort of
three dimensional data set with our axes
a B and C so we're going to have
something like this and then see you
guys office so this is a this is B and
this is C so maybe in this data set
you know instance 1 appears here and 2
over here and 3 over here and 4 over
here right you've just I'm imagine these
are in some sort of 3d space you know
perhaps intuitively we can say well ok
one is maybe closer to 4 than 2 is
because this is shorter distance but of
course this is a three dimensional space
is hard to visualize but doesn't matter
how many attributes we have we can still
say well ok in this space these
instances are closer to these instances
and then we can start grouping things
together so maybe I mean actually 2 is
very far away from free so maybe we sort
of group these two up and group these
two up or something like this so
typically we're going to use you're
clearly in distance for this right which
is going to be this best distance here
between points 1 & 2 in this 3
dimensional space there's obviously
going to be questions about how many
groups are we grouping them into it's 3
too far away to be in any of these
groups these are things we have to think
about but this applies to any number of
dimensions as just simply the only thing
holding you back is just how fast your
computer is and how fast
go food is we're gonna look at two
different clustering algorithms right
the first is going to be k-means and
then we're going to look at pam alright
which is slightly different now we
talked about k-means in computer file
before but we're going to talk about it
here for this course so just you know to
keep things simple for my arm and
drawing i'm gonna think the two
dimensions here and we've got some sort
of data right which is sort of looks
like this and there may be some more
data over here and you know to us we can
sort of say well maybe there's two
groups but we want to sort of formalize
this process and you've got to consider
that in two dimensions maybe it's quite
clear that there's two groups if you've
got a sort of n-dimensional space maybe
a thousand dimensions or ten thousand
dimensions picking out where the groups
are is not something you want to be
doing by hand
so what k-means does is it splits some
data into K groups right so I'm going to
specify them Oh strike straight away but
K is 2 in this case
because I think there are two classes
here now if I get that wrong obviously
that's a problem
we'll talk about that later but what
we're gonna do is we're gonna pick two
random points in this space so let's say
this one here and this one here so we've
got two classes and we're going to start
to assign each of these points based on
whichever of these means is closer so
these are the center points for our new
groups generally speaking obviously this
is going to be clearly in distance so
essentially a circle in this case so
we're going to sort of look sort of like
this and the blue one's going to come
around so kind of like this kind of like
this and these will probably be red
because they're slightly closer so now
but all these are red what we're going
to do is we're going to label these all
red I can only do one iteration of this
because now painted all over my picture
we start by assigning all of them now we
might be finished but let's imagine
we're not what we want to try and do is
reevaluate where the positions of our
clusters are based on this information
so we take the mean or the average
position of this group here the red
group and we can say well okay it's sort
of bang in the middle here so we get rid
of this one I'm gonna this above our pen
oh it worked
here's my new center position here right
the blue one which I'm going to have to
scribble out is going to move to our
about there something like this so
that's iteration one right now we've we
calculated these center points so this
blue region of what's going to be
classified as blue and what's going to
be classified as red it's kind of going
to move this way a little bit so I guess
we're going to maybe reevaluate and this
is going to become blue
ooh this is going to be an iterative
process we're going to keep
recalculating these means based on the
points that have moved back and forth
between these two groups and eventually
these means should begin to converge and
stop moving around as things settle down
and usually this actually happens pretty
quickly I even in a large dimensional
space k-means is a very popular
algorithm it's got a few drawbacks one
is that let's imagine we had a single
point way over here
an outlier right now hopefully you've
got rid of most of our lives from the
previous video but if you haven't and
you've got an outlier here that you
weren't expecting then what's going to
happen is this is going to be assigned
it in the first iteration to be blue
it's going to pull the mean of this
group this way which means that more of
them are going to be assigned red and
red is going to go this way as well and
it's just going to move the means around
and cause a bit of a problem
we might get away of it in this case but
you can imagine if you've got a large
high dimensional space and you're trying
to cluster lots and lots of clusters
getting the means in the wrong position
could cause a bit of instability cause
the wrong plate things to be classified
and clustered together there's a couple
more issues one is that you know where
you start your means on the first
iteration is obviously quite important
if you place it at random there's a
charge you're going to put it right up
here and things could take a lot longer
to converge or could settle on some
clustering that you're not happy with so
this outlaw is going to be a problem
right it's going to make K means
struggle slightly so as an alternative
we can use which is called Pam or
partitioning around meds by or Kay meds
whatever you want to call it instead of
calculating a mean for our cluster and
moving those means around what we're
going to do is use actual points from
our cluster so what we do is we start
off exactly the same as k-means but
instead of picking two random positions
we pick two random points so for example
what we'll do is we'll pick this red one
here and we'll pick this blue one here
now these are treated exactly like the
means in kami
so we've in cluster our data around
these two points and then we calculate
an error for each cluster that is the
distance from all the other points we
assign to it into that cluster so you
can imagine hopefully if this point has
been chosen in the middle of a cluster
then the distance will be quite small
because everything will be tightly bound
together if it's we're over here as an
outlier it's going to be a huge error
because the distance to all of these
points is massive so then what we do is
we pick a group at random and we move
the center to another point so we
okay we were here let's move to here and
we repartition our data and we calculate
a new error per distance to all our new
clusters based on this new position that
we just picked and if it's better we
permanently move our center point there
if it's not we go back to where we were
before we pick a new cluster at random
and a new point at random and we repeat
this process
so in k-means you move both means in
fact however many group clusters you've
got you're going to move all the means
at the same time right because you
repartition the data all the means are
going to move around and then you
reposition the data and you repeat like
this in Pam you just move one mean or
one exemplar or meadow at a time so
let's say you pick the red one first you
move that and maybe pick the red one
again and you move that and then it's
blues turn you move that and obviously
this is gonna take a little while to do
over time hopefully what will happen is
you find that more and more of a time
you try and move and it doesn't work
because you just increase the error
because you settled on something really
helpful and also eventually if you take
long enough doing this you're gonna
visit it all your points and then you
might as well stop as well so typically
what you would do is stop after you fail
a number of times to move somewhere
better because really you actually found
somewhere pretty good this neatly avoids
our problem of outliers because this one
here won't affect the position of this
cluster because if we ever chose it to
be a center it will be immediately
discarded because the error is so large
as opposed to it actually affecting the
mean and pulling this cluster this
direction so there's one last problem
and that is the problem of how did we
get this - I said that I thought there
were two clusters in this data and
happily there were and that worked out
really nicely but if you've got you know
a huge data set there's no way to guess
how many clusters this is going to be
and or if you do maybe that's not the
optimal number of clusters so for
example if you're trying to cluster up
songs and Spotify I mean how many
clusters is that I have no idea
like lots so you put 80 in and it's okay
but is that should you go up should you
do 100 or should you do 60 I don't know
so there are approaches like DB scan
which will try and bring in the concept
of a neighborhood and have the ability
to increase or decrease the number of
clusters as appropriate for your data
all right so what's going to happen is
they'll say this looks good but if we
split this in two and had two clusters
here instead that will be a better fit
right so these are very useful technique
so you can use if you want something a
little bit more powerful now it wouldn't
be a date of an artist course if we
didn't look at the iris dataset at least
once this is a classic data set everyone
uses and it's good for clustering nice
and small and we can have a look and
this data set we've got three different
species of flower we've got so Tosa
versicolor
and virginica we've got four attributes
we've got several length sepal width
petal length petal width just for this
occasion I looked up what a sepal is and
it's the green bit that covers the
flower when it's folded up right now I
don't know much about these flowers but
they are subtly different one of them is
a little bit more different than the
others so it makes for a good clustering
problem because we're hoping for three
distinct clusters the iris dataset is
one of the ones that's built into our
you can literally call data iris and
it'll load it up for you now let's have
a quick look at what we've got because
they're lovely function in are called
pairs which just shows us a load of
scatter plots of different attributes so
if I run this this is only going to work
for a few attributes before the whole
thing becomes very difficult to look at
so we've got things like sepal length
sepal width and the correlations of
these and these are colored by the
different class of flower so you can see
if the three class is one of them is
actually quite different a lot of the
time and then some of them bees this red
and green class they've got quite a lot
of overlap so clustering nose is going
to be a little bit more difficult
bearing in mind we're using four
dimensions to do it not the two you're
seeing in any individual scatter plot
okay so let's just start off with
standard k-means so we're going to call
km3 k-means with three clusters is
k-means there's a function for this in R
on the iris data set all of the rows 1
to 4 so not the species of plant we're
not going to custom on that three
clusters and we're going to allow it to
go 400 iterations k-means will stop
early if it doesn't improve itself but
if it keeps going maybe it's just going
back and forth a little bit it's time to
stop that did not take very long
this object returned by the k-means
function is going to have an integer
determining which of our instances have
been assigned to which cluster so all of
these first ones have been assigned to
cluster two and the Centers for all of
our clusters as well so remember that in
our we only have a data frame like this
iris we can add other columns to it so
we're going to just add our k-means
result back into our it's data frame so
we can keep track of it so we're going
to say iris km3 is equal to
km3 dollar cluster that's gonna be in
there okay
so let's put it in a table we'll have a
look at how our clusters match up to our
actual number of flowers we've got so
it's going to be a table of the irf
species versus the iris clusters from
k-means alright so if we have a look at
that the first thing we'll see is that
it doesn't make absolutely much sense
because for example say Tozer which is
our class 1 in some sense has been
assigned to cluster 3 so what we're
going to do is we're going to reorder
these columns so that the correct
classifications are down the diagonal
much like a confusion matrix so we have
a function to do that that we're going
to call and if we look at this result we
can see that the results are an 89%
classification accuracy there were 50 of
each plant in this dataset
48 of these plants have been correctly
assigned to cluster two together but two
of them were in cluster 1 along with the
other virginities and finally the
virginica has been 36 of 50 correctly
assigned to cluster 1 and 14 have been
incorrectly clustered into cluster 2
right so it worked pretty well it's not
perfect bearing in mind if you really
want to separate out plants maybe you
need more than 4 dimensions maybe you
can't absolutely tell what a plant is
just based on 4 dimensions
all right some of these plants are
similar enough but the clustering isn't
very well defined so perhaps we can make
our life a little bit easier by using
principal component analysis to do
dimensionality reduction or just to
reframe our data onto some different
axes to get better
clustering result so we're going to do a
very similar thing we're going to run
PCA on the iris dataset and we're going
to project our points into that new
principal component space and then we're
going to take only the first two
dimensions so this is principal
component 1 and principal component 2 as
we covered in the principal component
video then what we're going to do is
we're going to apply caming stavos
results rather than the original data so
what we've done is we've transformed our
4 dimensions of sepal width sepal length
petal length and petal width onto our
principal component axes and then we've
discarded the last two and kept just two
axes so I'm going to run that that
didn't take very long
ok we're going to sign that back to our
iris data set just like we did with the
results of k-means and then we can bring
up another table and see how the results
compare table to and then we'll order
that again by the diagonal
results were almost exactly the same I
think it was 88% 89% something like this
you can see that one extra versicolor
was put into cluster 2 when it shouldn't
have been I but this is with only 2
dimensions instead of 4 dimensions so
we've Harbor number of dimensions but by
using PCA we've got almost the exact
same result for datasets that you don't
have labels for maybe the labels are too
hard to get or you don't know what they
would be
I think clustering is a good way to
group up data and start to derive some
knowledge the knowledge we can derive or
what what items are similar to each
other by which products in our database
are similar to each other so that we can
start using them for a recommender
system you know what movies are like
each other what songs are like each
other like what flowers are like each
other so the ideas that were clustering
data up and by doing that we can look at
these clusters and start to gain some
knowledge don't forget also that each of
these is going to have a prediction as
well so this one here attribute one is
going to have let's say like a label if
we did play tennis or this person is
healthy or this person has this disease
it depends on you